alors aujourd'hui on va parler du
stoïcisme bon donc le stoïcisme
c'est un gros morceau ça correspond à la
période de l'antiquité on est au 3e
siècle avant jésus-christ donc c'est un
mouvement philosophique qui vient après
socrate platon aristote et c'est un
mouvement qui a perduré à travers les
siècles qui a subi pas mal de dévolution
voire de déformation alors c'est
toujours difficile d'aborder un grand
courant philosophique comme celui-là
parce que la question c'est de savoir
par quel bout par quel bout le prendre
et le problème se pose d'autant plus que
le stoïcisme correspond à ce qu'on
pourrait appeler une philosophie total
philosophie total c'est à dire que c'est
ce n'est pas seulement un système de
pensée un système de compréhension du
monde
c'est à la fois une philosophie
théorique et une philosophie pratique
c'est une philosophie qui est tourné à
la fois vers la compréhension mais aussi
vers l'action vers l'action dans le
monde et qui est donc destiné à
l'individu alors on va à partir de
quelques citations je donnerai des
citations de mémoire parce que je n'ai
pas je n'ai pas préparé la 7e cette
vidéo je préfère je préfère improvisée
de les dépister puis ensuite chacun
prend ce qu'il a envie de prendre et et
poursuit ses recherches
alors je vais partir d'une première
citation à laquelle on fait souvent
référence pour résumer le stoïcisme qui
est de dire il y à ce qui dépend de nous
il y as qui ne dépend pas de nous donc
la vision stoïcienne du monde elle est
déjà basées sur une première séparation
une séparation dont on doit prendre
conscience pour comprendre nos nos
limites de limites en tant qu'être
humain et ne limite en tant que
qu'individu il ya des choses qui
dépendent de nous par exemple
il dépend de moi de travailler pour
réussir
li dépend de moi de rechercher la vérité
dépend de moi de bien agir
il ne dépend pas de moi d'être grand
fort puissant il ne dépend pas de moi
d'être beau et ne dépend pas de moins de
naître à tel ou tel endroit
donc on arrive à assez bien à comprendre
en fait ce que disent les stoïciens il y
a ceux dont on hérite et il y a ce conte
ce qu'on construit par soi même
évidemment on pourra toujours répondre
que cette limite est assez floue par
exemple les stoïciens 10 qui ne dépend
pas de nous d'être riche
or on peut faire remarquer que basse il
dépend de nous d'être riches c'est à
dire que si je dirige mon action vers la
réussite matérielle financière
j'ai plus de chances d'être riche que si
je ne fais rien donc en ce sens
on pourra toujours trouver des des
points de détails sur lesquels ses
divisions entre ce qui dépend de nous et
ce qui ne dépend pas de nous est
discutable mais dans les grandes lignes
encore une fois on comprend ce que ça
veut dire prendre conscience de cette
distinction entre ce qui dépend de nous
et ce qui ne dépend pas de nous en fait
pour les stoïciens c'est juste un
premier pas
c'est le premier pas vers la conscience
que nous ne sommes pas en capacité de
tout ferme et que nous sommes
fondamentalement limité donc de ce point
de vue là la philosophie stoïcienne
c'est un appel à l'humilité l'humilité
qui n'est rien d'autre que la
reconnaissance de notre impuissance de
notre finitude
on peut le dire de manière inversée si
j'ai des souhaits ou des désirs ou des
ambitions totalement démesurée d'une
manière ou d'une autre je vais être
confronté à mes limites je ne vais pas
pouvoir accéder à tout ce que je
souhaite
et lorsque je rencontrerai des obstacles
à mes désirs
le problème c'est que je risque d'être
malheureux pour le dire de manière
synthétique
si je désire des choses impossibles
je vais souffrir je vais souffrir parce
que je vais m'en rendre compte que par
définition ce qui est impossible n'est
pas accessible
alors ça a l'air totalement évident et
banal de dire ça on peut se dire mais
c'est vraiment ça la philosophie dire
que ce qui est impossible est impossible
en quelque sorte c'est une tautologie
oui mais si les stoïciens apprennent la
peine de le préciser c'est parce que
dans notre comportement quotidien dans
notre comportement réel
on a tendance à l'oublier on a tendance
à croire que certaines choses peuvent
dépendre de nous alors qu'elles ne
dépendent pas et ils prennent quelques
exemples très concrets
premier exemple je sais j'ai conscience
que ma vie est limitée
mon existence sur cette terre est
limitée dans le temps et d'ailleurs
l'existence de tous les êtres humains
est limité donc lorsque quelqu'un meurt
et bien même si c'est quelqu'un à qui je
tenais beaucoup
même si c'est quelqu'un que j'aimais je
dois accepter sa disparition je dois
accepter la mort de cette personne
puisque c'est dans l'essence de l'être
humain de naître de vivre et de mourir
être triste parce que un être cher
meurent pour les stoïciens c'est d'abord
une aberration logique et c'est vrai
c'est une aberration logique
je ne peux pas faire en sorte que les
gens que j'aime soit éternelle c'est un
fait donc cette première limite de la
nature humaine qui est qui et la mort
donc la limite temporelle bien je dois
pas seulement savoir qu'elle existe je
dois l'accepter
et c'est là qu'on voit que chez les
stoïciens comprendre quelque chose
avoir conscience de quelque chose c'est
pas simplement savoir que ça existe
c'est l'accepter au plus profond de son
être et même au plus profond de sa chair
et c'est à ce moment là qu'on s'aperçoit
que la philosophie stoïcienne n'est pas
seulement une philosophie théorique mais
bien une philosophie pratique c'est à la
fois une philosophie et une psychologie
notre vie n'est pas éternel nous devons
accepter la mort 2
accepter notre propre mort alors epicure
disait apprendre à vivre c'est apprendre
à mourir et la philosophie c'est tout le
travail d'acceptation de la mort mais ce
n'est pas l'accepter comme quelque chose
de triste de regrettable
c'est accepter comme une nécessité c'est
l'accepter comme une loi de la nature et
c'est seulement à partir du moment où je
l'acceptent profondément comme une loi
de la nature que je peux m'émanciper de
la tristesse du chagrin de la souffrance
que cette idée normalement véhicule
si vous pensez l'instant vous essayez
d'imaginer à quel âge
en quel lieu dans quelles circonstances
est ce que vous allez mourir d'une mort
naturelle
ce que vous allez mourir dans votre
sommeil est ce que vous allez mourir
d'un d'un accident de voiture d'une
maladie incurable et a tout de suite ce
qui va vous envahir c'est un sentiment
d'angoissé et ce sentiment d'angoissé
pour les stoïciens il est la preuve que
d'une certaine manière vous n'avez pas
accepter l'idée de la mort alors on
retrouve beaucoup cette idée que ce soit
chez les stoïciens auch et les
épicuriens qui est de dire que la mort
n'est rien
la mort n'est rien pourquoi parce que
lorsque l'on vit bien la mort n'est pas
là et lorsqu'on meurt eh bien on n'est
plus là pour souffrir
donc finalement on ne rencontre jamais
la mort la mort nous emporte
mais en un claquement de doigts qui fait
qu' on n'a pas le temps de la voir donc
l'angoissé de la mort celle angoisses
d'une idée et non pas l' angoisse d'une
réalité celle angoisses d'une projection
mentale et c'est là qu'on commence à
s'approcher un petit peu plus du noyau
de la philosophie stoïcienne qui est le
rôle de l'art de la projection
imaginaire qui fait que l'individu n'est
jamais totalement dans sa réalité
présente on n'est jamais vraiment dans
dans l'instant présent
si on peut dire on est toujours dans
l'anticipation du futur
ou dans la nostalgie du passé mais au
final on n'est jamais réellement dans le
présent le problème de ces projections
c'est que elles font naître en nous des
des émotions des émotions que les
stoïciens appelé des passions donc c'est
l'ancien terme pour parler des émotions
à leur passion serre en grec
ça se dit pato ce bateau ce qui veut
dire souffrance et la passion c'est
aussi se fasse à quoi nous sommes passif
c'est ce que nous subissons la peur le
regret la jalousie l'envi la colère tout
ça ce sont des émotions ce sont des
passions mais ce sont des choses qui
sont d'abord des créations de notre
esprit et c'est la preuve que nous
n'acceptons pas l'existence telle
qu'elle est j'ai pris l'exemple de l'
angoisse de la mort mais on pourrait
prendre un tas d'autres exemples c'est
par exemple je suis jaloux de mon voisin
je suis jeune mon voisin parce qu'il a
une plus belle voiture que moi ou parce
qu'il a une plus belle femme comme moi
des plus beaux enfants que moi importe
bien cette jalousie c'est une projection
de mon esprit c'est à dire que si mon
voisin n'avait pas tout ce que je n'ai
pas je ne serais pas malheureux donc
c'est parce que mon voisin à ce que je
n'ai pas que j'ai cette frustration qui
se traduit par la jalousie mais dans ce
cas là ce n'est pas mon voisin qui
responsable c'est moi c'est moi qui
laisse cette pensée et les émotions qui
découle de cette pensée c'est moi qui
l'ait ses émotions prendre le dessus
prendre le dessus sur moi prendre le
dessus sur mon état affectif
donc j'en suis responsable donc ça
dépend de moi et là on en arrive à cette
idée des stoïciens qui est que je ne
dois pas être affecté par ce qui ne
dépend pas de moi
l'accord donc premier constat il y as
qui dépend de moins il y as qui n'en
dépend pas deuxième constat je ne dois
pas être affecté par ce qui ne dépend
pas de moi
je disais tout à l'heure que la peur de
la mort pour les stoïciens c'était une
aberration logique mais en fait pour les
stoïciens toute émotion est une
aberration logique pour une raison
simple qui est que une émotion ne résout
pas le problème qui en est la cause
alors en réalité pour les stoïciens la
cause de nos émotions c'est nous mêmes
mais nous nous identifions spontanément
la cause de nos émotions à quelque chose
d'extérieur à nous si je suis en colère
ce n'est pas de ma faute c'est parce
qu'on m'a rendu en colère c'est parce
qu'on m'a mis en colère pour les
stoïciens ça c'est de la foutaise
si on est en colère c'est parce qu'on
n'arrive pas à maîtriser nos émotions et
l'autre n'est qu'un prétexte pour
justifier notre colère c'est à dire pour
justifier notre incapacité à maîtriser
nos émotions nos émotions nous en sommes
responsables
une preuve de ça c'est qu'il y a des
personnes qui arrive très bien à gérer
leurs émotions
il ya des personnes qui arrivent à ne
pas se laisser perturber ou affectés par
des événements extérieurs y compris des
événements qui peuvent apparaître comme
extrêmement grave et pénible et
d'ailleurs ont dit ces personnes
qu'elles savent rester stoïque stoïque
dans le langage courant
ça signifie impassible impassible sans
passion c'est une forme d'indifférence
mais qui n'est pas une indifférence
disons liée à une absence de conscience
au contraire c'est une indifférence
maîtriser c'est une indifférence assumer
puisqu'elle correspond à la conscience
qu'il y à certaines choses qui ne
dépendent pas de nous et les stoïciens
nous disent pourquoi être affectés de ce
qui ne dépend pas de toi ça ne résoudra
pas le problème
la colère ne va pas faire disparaître
les raisons de la colère
la jalousie ne va pas faire disparaître
les raisons de la jalousie pour les
stoïciens les émotions
c'est un petit peu là la chaleur que
produit une énergie que nous n'arrivons
pas à canaliser
alors on a besoin d'extérioriser cette
énergie par une émotion mais ça ne
résout pas le problème
si je me cogne le genou contre le coin
de ma table basse j'aurai beau insultait
ma table basse ou lui taper dessus
ça ne va pas faire disparaître ma
douleur quoique ça va me permettre de
dépenser l'énergie qui est dû à ma
douleur et à la colère qui résulte de
cette douleur si je regarde une émission
télé avec pour invité principal bhl
j'aurais beau l'insulté et jeté ma
télécommande eux à travers ma télé ça ne
résoudra rien donc ce que nous disent
les stoïciens c'est que il ne sert à
rien d'être dans l'émotion et que à
travers nos émotions en réalité on
masque notre incapacité à accepter le
monde tel qu'il est c'est pour ça qu'une
autre des citations des stoïciens c'est
de dire ne cherche pas à changer la
réalité mais a changé le point de vue
que tu as sur la réalité
alors là évidemment on va se dire mais
qu'est ce que c'est que cette
philosophie qui est finalement une
philosophie de la soumission
une philosophie de la passivité c'est
légitime de dire ça si j'accepte tout
c'est une forme de renoncement
ça revient à dire je dois accepter les
injustices je dois accepter par exemple
que l'on puisse me mentir que l'on
puisse me voler que l'on puisse me
tromper je dois accepter l'immoralité de
mon voisin parce que les stoïciens me
disent que si je n'accepte pas et bien
je suis dans la folie
oui et non n'oubliez pas que les
stoïciens font la différence entre ce
qui dépend de moi est ce qui ne dépend
pas de moi
il ya des choses sur lesquelles je peux
avoir un contrôle et les stoïciens nous
disent bien
donne moi la force de changer ce qui
peut l'être
donc la première difficulté c'est de
savoir qu'est-ce qui peut être changé et
d'agir à mon niveau sur ce qui peut être
changé mais je ne dois pas avoir des
prétentions qui sont au-delà de mes
moyens je ne dois pas penser que je suis
capable de révolutionner le monde tout
seul avec mes petits bras
je dois accepter que seuls les
changements que je peux apporter et
transformations que je peut opérer sur
le monde
eh bien elles seront à l'image de mes
capacités
c'est à dire pas grand chose
relativement au monde
pas grand chose mais j'ai le choix entre
faire ce que je peux faire et laisser
tomber en dix ans après tout ça sert à
rien j'ai le choix je peux accepter de
renoncer de dire à quoi bon mais dans ce
cas là pour les stoïciens je ne fais pas
ce qui dépend de moi j'abandonne je
renonce je démissionne mais pourquoi
parce que je ne supporte pas l'idée de
ne pas avoir plus d'emprise sur le monde
donc en fait je renonce par ego je
renonce pas ce que je dis de toute façon
à moi tout seul je ne pourrai pas opérer
les changements que je souhaite opérer
d'accord mais ça c'est un raisonnement
qui est dictée par lego qui est dicté
par l'émotion qui est dictée par le
sentiment et le désir de toute puissance
mais là pour les stoïciens on est
toujours dans l'aberration donc pour les
stoïciens on agit sur le périmètre sur
lequel on peut agir et on ne se
préoccupe pas du reste on ne se soucie
pas du reste parce que le reste ne nous
appartient pas
ce que le reste appartient au monde et
que le monde poursuit son chemin sans
nous nous faisons partie du monde nous
déposons sur lui notre empreinte
mais nous ne sommes pas propriétaires il
appartient à nous en tant qu'individu de
faire des choses dont nous sommes
capables
il ne nous appartient pas en tant
qu'individu d'agir à la place des autres
donc plutôt que d'une philosophie du
renoncement moi je parlerais plutôt
d'une philosophie de la lucidité je
pense hélas c'est un jugement tout à
fait personnelle que les personnes
qu'ils accomplissent de grandes choses
sont des personnes qui ne se soucie pas
de ce qu'elles ne sont pas capables de
faire ce sont des personnes qui se
soucient exclusivement de ce qu'elles
sont capables de faire avoir des rêves
inatteignable c'est le meilleur moyen de
ne jamais en réaliser un seul désirer
l'impossible c'est le meilleur moyen de
rester dans l'inaction donc dans la
passivité et donc dans la frustration
qui accompagne nécessairement cette
passivité la philosophie des stoïciens
est une philosophie pratique parce que
c'est une philosophie qui nous pousse à
mettre nos actes en conformité avec nos
pensées on disait tout à l'heure si
j'évolue dans les émotions telles que la
colère la jalousie leurs sentiments mes
actions porteront la marque de ses
émotions
au contraire si j'agis dans l'
enthousiasme si j'agis dans une sorte de
de gaieté de joie inconditionnels de
joie qui n'a pas besoin de raison d'être
et bien pour les solutions je suis
beaucoup plus libres car je ne dépends
pas de mes émotions car je ne dépend pas
d'une ambition irréaliste je ne dépends
pas de l'illusion pour les stoïciens nos
émotions nous rang d'esclave
c'est très clair
nos émotions nous empêche de voir et de
comprendre la réalité telle qu'elle est
c'est comme un filtre qu'on mettrait
entre nous et la réalité et qui du même
coup déformerait cette réalité à nos
yeux
si je pars du principe que le monde a
existé avant - et qu'il existera
toujours après moi bien d'un coup ça ça
relativise ma capacité d'action et de
transformation de ce monde mais ça ne
veut pas dire que je ne suis capable de
rien ça veut dire que j'ai conscience
des limites dans lesquelles je peux agir
les émotions nous rende esclaves puisque
par définition nous ne choisissons pas
d'avoir des émotions
en fait pour les stoïciens il serait
plus juste de dire que nous subissons
nos émotions parce que nous ne faisons
pas l'effort qu'il faut pour les
maîtriser les stoïciens pense que le but
de l'existence humaine c'est d'atteindre
le bonheur et la sagesse puisque pour
eux la sagesse c'est la condition du
bonheur et la sagesse est liée aussi à
la connaissance à la compréhension
je comprends le monde je comprends la
manière dont il fonctionne je
l'acceptent et parce que je les accepte
je peux être heureux il ya une phrase de
de sartre pour le coup qui résume assez
bien en fait le point de vue des
stoïciens qui est de dix ans
l'important n'est pas ce qu'on a fait de
nous mais ce qu'on fait de ce qu'on a
fait de nous ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que nous avons tous un
caractère ou ou un tempérament
même si il convient de distinguer ces
deux notions et nous sommes tous plus ou
moins enclins à à ressentir à éprouver
des émotions des passions ça ça ne
dépend pas entièrement de nous il ya des
gens qui sont plutôt colérique il ya des
gens qui sont plutôt calmes
il ya des gens qui sont plutôt inquiet
d'autres qui sont plutôt paisible c'est
vrai mais rien ne nous empêche de
travailler sur ça rien ne nous empêche
de prendre conscience de ce
de ce caractère qui est le nôtre est de
travailler à le changer puisque ça c'est
dans nos possibilités et pour changer ça
et bien ça passe par une démarche de
compréhension du monde et de ses lois
la vision stoïcienne du monde est une
vision déterministe
ça veut dire que pour les stoïciens tout
ce qui arrive dans l'univers arrive pour
une certaine raison alors pour une
certaine raison ça ne signifie pas qu'il
y a des dieux qui tire des ficelles et
qui nous pousse à agir dans un sens
plutôt que dans un autre
on pourrait le résumer comme ça et ce
serait un peu trop simpliste et puis
surtout il y en a qui dirait à c'est
encore une vision religieuse ça
m'intéresse pas c'est pas pour moi
non c'est pas aussi simple cela consiste
à dire que quand quelque chose se
produit mais c'est qu'il y a des causes
à ce à cet événement aucun événement de
ce produit sans cause
donc quand on dit que tout a une raison
en fait on veut dire que tout a une
cause mais le mot raison est intéressant
on verra pourquoi tout ce qui arrive à
une cause ou un ensemble de cause ce qui
fait qu'on peut expliquer tout ce qui
arrive expliqué ne signifie pas accepter
automatiquement et expliquer ne signifie
pas non plus justifier au sens de
légitimer sur le plan normatif sur le
plan moral
par exemple si un homme commet un crime
on peut expliquer son crime par un
diagnostic médical psychologique
psychiatrique
on dira par exemple que c'est quelqu'un
qui a subi lui même des violences
extrêmes qui est devenu ce qu'on appelle
un psychopathe et qu'il est passé à
l'acte bien mais ça ne justifie pas son
geste au sens où ça ne l'excusé pas pour
les sto
siens cette distinction entre expliqué
est excusé elle n'a pas vraiment lieu
d'être quand je dis qu'elle n'a pas lieu
d'être évidemment qu'elle a lieu d'être
dans dans le cadre social mais elle n'a
pas lieu d'être au sens où si une chose
arrive c'est que de toute façon elle
avait des raisons d'arrivée c'est que de
toute façon elle a des causes puisque
rien n'arrive sans cause tout ce qui
arrive est un effet de cause qui le
précède
donc si on était capable du point de vue
de notre connaissance d'identifier
toutes les causes de ce qui arrive
eh bien on s'apercevrait qu'en fait tout
est normal et je devrais dire plutôt que
tout est normal c'est un terme qui prête
toujours à polémique
tout est logique tout est rationnel
tout est rationnel la raison englobe
tout ce qu'il est possible de comprendre
et si quelque chose se produit c'est que
cette chose avait des causes et ses
causes sont compréhensibles
je ne dis pas que nous sommes capables
de d'identifier toutes les causes de ce
qui arrive mais on est capable de savoir
que ses co existent je prendre l'exemple
de la coïncidence la fameuse coïncidence
vous rencontrez quelqu'un ça faisait un
petit moment que vous l'aviez pas vu et
vous le rencontrez dans un contexte
totalement improbable c'est pas possible
qu'on se rencontre ici là maintenant
quelle coïncidence
la coïncidence ou plutôt le sentiment de
la coïncidence extraordinaire c'est
quelque chose qu'on a tous déjà vécu
mais qui pour les stoïciens correspond
seulement à notre point de vue
individuel et si on voulait être un peu
méchant en dire et qui correspond à
notre point de vue d'ignorants
d'ignorants parce qu'en fait nous sommes
surpris de quelque chose quand nous n'en
connaissons pas les causes c'est ça en
fait la surprise on ignore les causes
mais si on avait connu les causes de
l'événement avant que cet événement se
produise on aurait été capable de
l'anticiper on aurait été capable de le
prédire
comme étant la conséquence logique
rationnelle nécessaire
de ses causes je prendre une image
imaginez que vous êtes dans le ciel et
que vous avez vu sur une ville vous
voyez toutes les rues entre les
immeubles et donc vous voyez toutes les
personnes qui s'y déplacent et donc vous
êtes capable de voir à quel moment deux
personnes vont se croiser à un angle de
rue parce que vous avez le point de vue
omniscient
vous êtes au dessus et donc vous voyez
la rencontre avant que la rencontre
n'ait lieu pour vous rien n'est
surprenant mais pour les individus qui
se rencontrent et qui se rentrent dedans
au coin de la rue c'est extraordinaire
donc on est dans une question de point
de vue en fait la surprise l'étonnement
la coïncidence le sentiment de
coïncidence c'est un sentiment qui est
propre à l'individu
mais si l'individu était capable de
s'élever du point de vue rationnel c'est
à dire du point de vue objectif du point
de vue omniscient et bien en fait il ne
serait pas surpris il s'y attendrait
pour les stoïciens rien de ce qui arrive
n'est étonnant parce qu'ils adoptent ce
point de vue omniscient parce qu'ils
savent que lorsque quelque chose se
produit c'est qu'il y avait des raisons
que ça se produise et ses salles
déterminisme c'est le fait de se dire
que tout ce qui arrive est l'effet
nécessaire c'est-à-dire fatale de cause
qui précède cet événement pour les
stoïciens l'univers est totalement
rationnelle
s'il est rationnel il obéit aux lois de
la logique
il est donc compréhensible dans sa
totalité si le réel et rationnelle si le
réel est logique
l'homme doit dans la mesure du possible
se conformer à ce modèle de rationalité
l'homme en tant que partie de l'univers
doit chercher à se comporter comme cet
univers plus il se comportera comme
l'univers c'est à dire de manière
rationnelle et logique et moins sera
soumis à la souffrance à la frustration
à la tristesse
bref - il sera soumis à ces émotions
plus il se rapprochera de ce modèle de
rationalité et plus il sera libre et
plus il sera libre plus sera heureux le
bonheur c'est lorsque je deviens capable
de ne plus dépendre de mes émotions qui
sont comme des sangsues qui m'empêche de
déployer nos potentiels rationnelle
alors évidemment pourra dire mais qu'est
ce que c'est que ce modèle totalement
inhumain oui effectivement on peut
considérer que c'est quelque chose
d'absolument inaccessible à l'être
humain ce cette capacité d'objectivité
absolu qui fait qu'on ne va plus
dépendre de ses émotions
on peut le considérer mais les stoïciens
s'en foutent les stoïciens se disent est
ce qu'on est capable d'aller vers cet
idéal
est ce qu'on est capable de se déprendre
de l' influence de nos émotions
oui on est capable on en est capable
mais c'est pas facile évidemment que
c'est pas facile mais les stoïciens
n'ont jamais dit que la sagesse était
quelque chose de facile les philosophes
d'une manière générale n'ont jamais dit
que le bonheur ou la connaissance
étaient des choses faciles ils disent
c'est possible c'est faisable
la preuve que c'est faisable puisque on
peut en forme et le projet donc oui on
peut se débarrasser on peut vaincre nos
émotions et c'est par ce travail de
combat contre nos émotions qu'on peut
aller vers la sagesse et le bonheur le
bonheur pour les stoïciens ce n'est en
aucun cas la satisfaction de ses désirs
pour eux satisfaire ses désirs c'est le
contraire du bonheur alors si vous
m'avez suivi jusque là vous devriez
devinez pourquoi pourquoi est ce que le
bonheur c'est le contraire de la
satisfaction du désir
et bien parce que le désir c'est quelque
chose qui ne dépend pas de nous le désir
c'est un sentiment qui nous habite
un sentiment qui peut même devenir
physique et qui vient manifester notre
manque d'un objet extérieur
je désire quelque chose que je n'ai pas
définition mais lorsque je le désire je
prouve que je dépends de cet objet en
tout cas je le prouve que mon bonheur
dépend d'eux cet objet et je vais
spontanément associer mon bonheur à
l'acquisition de l'objet que je désire
ça pour les stoïciens c'est une
c'est une illusion totale et d'ailleurs
je pense que chacun d'entre vous vous
pouvez en faire l'expérience
si vous désirez quelque chose vous avez
envie d'une cigarette par exemple comme
moi en ce moment
ben vous aller fumer votre cigarette et
puis quand vous l'aurez terminé il va
pas vous falloir longtemps avant d'avoir
envie de la prochaine donc vous n'aurez
pas tuer votre désir au sens où vous ne
l'aurez pas satisfait donc la cigarette
que je suis en train de fumer
actuellement elle ne me rend pas heureux
elle comble un désir elle comble un
manque mais qui ne manquera pas de
ressurgir dans quelques temps donc le
bonheur c'est pas obtenir quelque chose
qu'on désire le bonheur c'est ne plus
dépendre de ses désirs le bonheur c'est
ne plus désirés je désire quelque chose
lorsque je suis en manque
fatalement lorsque je ne suis plus en
manque
lorsque je suis comblé bien je ne désire
plus on peut être heureux dans la
maladie on peut être heureux dans la
solitude
on peut même être heureux dans la
souffrance physique
d'ailleurs ça me fait penser à une autre
citation d'epictète epictète était un
esclave puisqu'il y avait des esclaves
qui était stoïciens vous allez me dire
ah ben il valait mieux être stoïciens
canton étaient esclaves ça a aidé à
supporter c'est vrai mais il y avait
aussi des empereur qui était stoïciens
comme marc aurèle par exemple epictète
un moment donné rapporte une anecdote il
disait que on essayait de lui casser le
bras en lui faisant une clef quoi tordre
ans et il avait dit tu vas finir par me
casser ce bras
et puis bah son bras se casser lire ben
tu vois je te l'avais bien dit donc
c'est une citation un peu amusant pour
dire que le stoïcien total le stoïcien
accompli c'est celui qui est capable
d'être dans la lah pur constatations
sans aucune émotion et sans aucune
expression de de souffrance alors oui on
peut considérer que c'est un idéal un
peu difficile à atteindre mais je ferais
remarquer que certaines personnes
humaines de notre époque sont capables
d'atteindre ce genre d'état ce qu'on
appelle les les yogis qui sont capables
d'endurer une souffrance absolument
intolérable par un détachement de
l'esprit donc les stoïciens préconise
effectivement ce genre de pratiques
notamment la pratique de la méditation
qui est un un canal vers la sagesse au
sens où la méditation nous permet de
nous concentrer sur notre conscience
plutôt que sur notre corps
alors je vais essayer de conclure les
stoïciens nous disent qu'il y a ce qui
dépend de nous et et ce qui ne dépend
pas de nous et qu'il ne dépend que de
nous de ne plus être dépendant de ce qui
ne dépend pas de nous pour les stoïciens
l'univers obéit à des lois des lois
implacables ce qu'on pourrait appeler
les lois de la fatalité mais la fatalité
n'a pas chez les stoïciens une
connotation négative
d'ailleurs si on veut être un peu
honnête c'est surtout dans nos sociétés
contemporaines que la notion de fatalité
a une connotation négative puisque on
considère qu'à partir du moment où il ya
fatalité il y a absence de libre arbitre
mais pour les stoïciens c'est pas du
tout ça le libre arbitre existe pour les
stoïciens au sens où il dépend de nous
de ne pas nous affecter de ne pas nous
émouvoir de la nécessité implacable du
monde
il dépend de nous il ne dépend que de
nous d'être heureux dans la situation
qui est la nôtre
ce qui n'implique pas que nous devons
être passifs face à l'existence
face à ce qui arrive ce qui implique
seulement que nous devons faire preuve
de discernement de lucidité sur ce qui
peut être changé sur les raison de
changer ce qui doit l'être et sur les
moyens à employer pour changer ce qui
doit l'être le stoïcisme c'est une
philosophie pratique d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui le stoïcisme c'est en
quelque sorte converti dans les
techniques de développement personnel je
n'ai rien contre les techniques de
développement personnel
je pense simplement que elles sont un un
aspect superficiel de quelque chose de
beaucoup plus profond qui est une
philosophie à part entière on ne peut
pas simplement prendre l'aspect pratique
de la philosophie stoïcienne et se dire
que ça suffit non
puisque pour les stoïciens cette
capacité à maîtriser ses émotions cette
capacité à redevenir le le capitaine sur
le paquebot de notre existence
cette capacité là ne peut être que le
résultat d'une démarche de compréhension
du monde
comprendre le monde ne signifie pas
l'accepter mais il est impossible de
l'accepter si on ne cherche pas à le
comprendre comprendre le monde sait
comprendre que ce qui arrive à des
raisons d'arriver et que ce qui est est
le seul arbitre je peut déplorer à titre
individuel une situation mais il
n'empêche que cette situation a une
raison d'être
et peu importe si je n'en comprends pas
le sens peu importe si je n'en comprends
pas les causes il n'empêche que cette
situation est là et je ne peut que
l'accepter
il ne sert à rien de résister face à ce
qui est implacable il ne sert à rien de
s'énerver parce qu'il pleut ou parce
qu'il fait froid ça n'arrangera rien
quoique si je m'énerve je peux au moins
me réchauffer c'est déjà ça mais si
j'accepte ce qui met à priori
désagréable eh bien ça cesse d'être
désagréable personnellement j'utilise
beaucoup le stoïcisme quand je lis
certains commentaires sur mes vidéos je
me dis bon il ya une raison à ça donc
j'accepte
c'est très pratique le stoïcisme et
surtout c'est une philosophie qui agit
sur nous lorsqu'on lorsqu on en lit des
fragments je vous conseille vraiment de
lire les pensées de marc aurèle pensée
pour moi même et vous allez vous
apercevoir qu en lisant vous avez une
sensation étrange d'apaisement au fur et
à mesure de la lecture comme si
l'évidence logique implacable du ce que
vous lisez vous équilibrez vous alignez
à l'intérieur et lorsque vous êtes dans
cet état d'esprit lorsque vous êtes dans
cet état de neutralité par rapport à vos
émotions vous vous rendez compte
qu'effectivement tout est justifiée d'un
point de vue rationnel en tout cas tout
est justifié et que si la vie ne se
limite pas à la raison eh bien il n'y a
pas de raison que la vie soit une longue
succession de souffrance merci à vous